[Applause]
it's always so weird seeing you in this
setting yeah I love it try to pretend
like this is Mario do you know each
other we did just meet oh okay I mean I
feel like I've known him of course
congratulations on
everything
nomination all of
it too I thank you I remember though
when you and Brandy Clark started like a
decade ago it was a decade ago yes I
think I even went to smack songs I think
I went to your place when yall were
riding one day for but I was like this
has been a passion project for a minute
it has been and I mean we really didn't
know anything so our na Nativity
nativity naivity naivity
scene nativity scene nativity scene it
really helped though because you know
people along the way especially when we
get into the Broadway World we'd be like
oh we're writing a Broadway musical and
they'd be like H good luck and you know
well because so many people try to do it
and they also I thought you know we'll
will definitely go faster than what they
say because most of these shows take 10
years a lot of work and and it took 10
years every bit of it it's actually the
same changed it's morphed it's the same
age as like at my kids I'm just say it
was yeah sorry to interrupt you but yeah
it's the the the week we first started
uh her and Robert horn the bookwriter
they came to Palm Springs where the kids
were born yeah and we sat down and we
all started working that week so the age
of the kids has more and they're almost
11 so uh oh my gosh yeah so the show has
changed I mean it it's more many times
we had an out of town back in Texas uh
six years ago we had another out of town
in Salt Lake that's what you do is you
kind of get it in front of an audience
and let you know let them tell you what
works and what doesn't work and yeah it
it it's been an amazing experience so
the greatest thrill Pony nominated
that's incredible who would have thought
mineral wells just making it on the map
minerals I love it you you did Broadway
as well was it a I did a course on
that's right that's what happened to met
my wife so Broadway is always special to
me and I love I love musicals oh wait
nice outfit I love it I'm looking at
that cuz I keep going what are they
looking
at pictures so explain shucked for
everybody because it's had many lives
but what did it end up being so it is
the story it's a fable it's set in this
fictional Place sort of in the middle of
the country we assume called Cobb County
and basically everything they do uh
revolves around corn they've they've
made their life around corn yeah uh they
grow it they sell it they eat it they
live off of it and you can surprisingly
do a lot of things with corn I mean we
actually wrote a song call Corn that
opens the show that lists like 200 ways
that you can use corn it's amazing it is
Iowa what Iowa do Forest Gump with
shrimp it's exactly you're like sweet
corn yeah exactly so wait the cast is
performing later right what's the song
they're doing so they're doing a song
called We love Jesus actually
interesting enough it's the first song
we wrote for the show 11 years ago and
it got taken out many times during the
years and right or throughout the years
and right before we opened three days
before we opened on Broadway they put it
back in what yeah because uh we had
tried different things to open the
second act I mean you know how like
sometimes you get in front of an
audience and some things work song they
did at the Macy's Thanksgiving no that
was corn that's the open that I was
going to say okay CU I know I saw it at
the corn you know very creative name for
a show about corn and so this song is uh
called we love Jesus and um I'm so
excited it it probably will seem a
little strange out of context because it
it has a a guy that you're going to meet
soon who is sort of an outsider in this
world yeah and so he's the city guy
that's sort of hatching a plan to to
take some things from these people take
advantage yeah exactly thank you for
helping me through this nity I feel like
I'm on one of the game shows and Kelly
and I we're gonna win um so anyway he's
kind of uh being pushed around in this
number and it's really cute but if you
haven't seen it or no you'd be like what
is that white dude doing in the middle
of all these people getting pushed out
of town yeah you know now that's the
best tease ever everybody can't wait to
see this number now exactly joining us
now are two of the performers from the
show everybody say hello and give it up
to gray Henson and John
Bellman I have to say you both look
sharp but that suit is like my favorite
well I know I wish I could take credit
but it's a costume from the show oh my
God I love it yeah everyone backstage in
the makeup room Miami Vice like but in
the 70 like I just I'm very into it so
explain everybody who your characters
are well so I Am The Outsider in the
show the aforementioned uh white man
um um and uh and so I'm I'm a I'm a
Florida man basically so you nailed it
right on like na that giving Florida man
then and I'm kind of a two-bit con man
who comes to town to kind of help save
the dying corn yeah turns out spoiler
alert I don't know how to save the dying
corn and uh High Jinx and Sue I kind of
get roped into a potential wedding which
is kind of what the song is about that
you'll see and yeah um yeah but that's
me I'm Gordy okay and I so you're not
nice okay I'm nice I'm the villain with
a nice little heartful turn at the end
yes he does it really well yeah oh I
love Redemption Redemption I play
Storyteller number two in the show which
sounds sounds so lackluster sounds like
an extra but it's not and one of the the
one
he's one of the biggest characters of
the show we just couldn't think of an
when I got the audition I was like it's
Storyteller number two huh like Barista
3 and Gilmore Girls but
um I am I am one of the narrators yeah
the the gay
one I love you so much I can see why you
got hired right off the bat okay you're
making oh Glow's going to hate me my
makeup artist okay so wait so you have a
tradition at the show right I love this
tradition so we share a dressing room at
our theater and every week we award
someone something called the shucky
which is this like uh little statue John
crafted with his children right and um
we give it every week to it's like
employee of the week and so we give it
every week to someone that has gone like
above and beyond in the building and we
would like to do our weekly award here
on air if we could do we have the
shuy so here it is oh my God it's corn
John made at home um with hand painted
and mounted from some old thing I had in
my house and he's prepared a speech
Kelly we are so thankful that you chose
to break away from Los Angeles the West
Coast has been a little less bright
since you've been gone but New York is
stronger with you in it the chemistry is
real all I ever wanted was for shuck to
be the first Broadway show to perform on
your show in a moment like this I don't
know the meaning of life my God but
gratitude has got got to be part of it
so we made the shucky piece by piece and
now we present it to you thank you so
now shucky in hand when Christmas comes
around and you're underneath the tree
you can tell yourself this is my
December this is M it's
my that was good the
M thank you so much my life would shop
without
you is that amazing he said my life
would shook without you and I would like
to thank Texas and who El for all of us
just raising all of us what's funny is I
really assumed I was the one getting the
shule I even moved up you're you like
ready for your moment got the emotional
face not your time it's my time it's my
time like
[Music]
Goonies
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home